fouillouse thècle en bon français c'est
un salon consacré aux nouvelles
technologies de l'alimentation un salon
unique en france qui regroupe près d'une
centaine de start up
[Musique]
ces jeunes pousses innovantes propose
des idées dans différents domaines dans
la production dans la transformation
dans la distribution et la consommation
comme cette imprimante 3d qui n'est pas
réservé uniquement à la pâtisserie
madame bonjour bonjour oui nous
imprimons tous les patins alimentaire du
sucré du salé vins primés des légumes et
on peut imprimer comme la vous le voyez
du chocolat on a commencé par le
chocolat on s'adresse aux artisans et
aussi aux industriels avec différentes
formules de vente de location et de
partage de machines bien sûr toutes ces
start up sont ici à la recherche
d'investisseurs alors nous sommes avec
eux l'une des responsables de la banque
publique d'investissement dites-moi
est-ce qu'ils sont vraiment bons
endroits
tout à fait les start up sont là pour
les investisseurs pour faire du business
nous en tant que banque publique
d'investissement on les accompagne dans
leur croissance
depuis la création jusqu'au
développement de leurs projets
d'innovation des anglicismes nombreux et
un sens du marketing évident ici la
plupart des start-up surf sur la vague
des services numériques pour accompagner
le consommateur
alors véritable innovation ou simple
gadget ou le voit déjà avec des
applications
wajoka plusieurs millions de
téléchargements on voit déjà que c'est
très présent tout le monde un smartphone
tout le monde a envie d'avoir les
nouvelles technologies pour les aider
qu'est ce que je mange ce soir c'est une
question que se posent 27 millions de
foyers tous les jours donc si j'ai une
solution digital pour m'aider ça va la
plupart de ces applications et produits
sont destinés au grand public
ce salon professionnel sera d'ailleurs
ouvert à tous demain après midi
[Musique]